I am entered I have I forgot to enter
many times here we go
129 players 1829 average rating time
handicapped here we go here we go here
we go give me a little ticker well there
it is there's a little ticker it's been
a while since I played in one of these
close to a month close to a month oh
this could be a beautiful start could be
a beautiful start double the points in
command it's 15 seconds oh what's going
on here
yes double those points back to
tournament land twos 2 2 2 2 why wasn't
I not moving right away the English why
am I playing the English is this gonna
be another one what a beautiful start to
non movers to begin yes back to
tournament who has six it's six who all
right I'm gonna nan mover my way to
first place right there
imagine that juicy ketchup is gonna play
I guarantee it Oh is he gonna move yes
he is
or she you never know you just call him
they just to be sure you call them thing
they all right we've seen this before
you've seen it before I don't think I've
let's get my Bishop on this diagonal my
mom I'm gonna attack this Knight uh-oh I
should I should have stopped here first
no I want to get on these dark squares
let's throw this pawn up still okay dark
Square weaknesses Queen here it's not
really working recapture with the pun
he's gonna be a giant thorn long term my
queen is there to stay she has to be
kicked
can I really do that and get away with
it okay the queens are coming off got to
defend this pond come over with this
rook to defend hang on let's attack that
pond first he's being defended I should
have played this now I'm gonna do that
pond push is good no I have this let's
do this I should have done that instead
make up my mind okay here we go rook
position rook position
okay this pond is dead if look back over
here I take because it's not protected I
really take back rank issues come back
over here pawn push let's get out of
sneaky tricks avoid the sneaky tricks
pawn takes rook takes pawn next he's
marching he is marching oh that's a free
rook this is close to me very close to
me I just want to keep that King cut off
grab this pawn swing over here and it's
matin too close to me and one two three
two one back to tournament twelve twelve
twelve Dillon is up there Dillon has
given me beatings before Dillon has
given me beatings before I have to get
Dillon back yes I do
just get developed clean here maybe I
shouldn't have pre moved that that would
have been bad if the bishop took the
knight right right here so I could
preserve my light square bishop will
have the opportunity yes I will and now
I'm looking for tricks involving h7 it's
being ignored though that was being
ignored it can't be ignored this is
gonna lead to me right GG Bishop move
discovered tricks even if the pawn
pushes just take that same story nothing
has changed same story nothing has
changed
same story that's me back to tournament
land 2020 12 12 10 26 minutes remaining
okay
Castle castle 77 d5 no matter what hang
on let's try c5 still well I was ready
to move that pond okay hang on there
might be get that Bishop out of there he
is just a bug
he's a giant bug oh I think I just want
to kick that bishop away and get on the
lung oh now he's just dead cooked Bishop
cooked fish up here - was that a mouse
lip probably Bishop here was men he's
not gone anywhere
let's get developed actually pawn push
no my bishops okay I could do this just
get a Center complete my development
yeah he's still not going anywhere
Queen trade still not going anywhere
get my bishop doing something else
pinpoint this pond he's still not going
anywhere
Knight here next bad news on c2 mate
threat take the queen is dead come
another night involved but I should have
probably just pushed that pawn probably
missed a bunch of stuff okay
the bishop saved but this is big trouble
very very big trouble
all right
I was just ready to move my knight that
would not have been good okay let's just
take pieces his check
grab that Bishop grab the night actually
the game is not gonna finish doesn't
matter
back to tournament 30 no time remaining
30 30 22 16 double those points against
Buster boy 91
alright Scandinavian Scandinavian the
opening I said that one time in someone
I think commented that that player
wasn't Scandinavian he was from Spain or
something referring to the opening okay
now we get on this open file and what is
that King to do he's got to run scared
he's not running scared
the knight is dead the king is running
for the hills the bishops want to play
they resigned back to tournament 40 to
30 24 22 oh man a lot of time remaining
let's go with King sight fianchetto
get my Knights connected make sure that
there's I mean I should do this let's
let's do this hit that clean jump in on
on that point
Queen is dead pins Bishop here I could
take my Knights there I'd have a quick
resigner I'm on the rook on the other
hook I'm on the other up the bishops hit
he's not moving
restrict this Knight attack the knight
get my pieces all working trade trade
trade in the knight attack the knight of
he's defended he's dead no matter what
alright let's just do this because
that's check they resigned back to
tournament 56 42:26
a lot of place one of this is almost
maxed out and 145 players won thank oh
gee there was okay why am I going with
the mainline caro-kann let's avoid that
exchange I'm a counsel clean side they
ready for that we're gonna see a jump my
knight in to d6 d6 this part could be
taken he's not being taken and now I'm
getting material got out of checks the
Queen could have played there I want to
negate this diagonal okay with the
exchanges rooks come off I get my other
hook on the D file let's do this with f4
to follow I want to keep my bishop here
my bishop looks foolish but I'm doing
this with this that pawn structure can't
be can't be there I don't want this
night to get out of control look out for
there may be it this night I think I
could just take that and then take this
and get my pawn up a drop back here saw
my bishop be defended let's lock this
Bishop up and pin the night I just want
to get rid of the knight just get rid of
that triki triki night he's not going
anywhere let's box him out King position
next ideally on a dark square getting
maybe be four stop this Knight move a 3
B 4 he's still not gonna bother me I
don't think I can push him around a
little bit more okay he's being a pest
he's being a little bit of a pest get
rid of that tricky night and everything
could be pretty much pre moved all right
here one accurate move kill the night
and then everything else is much easier
now let's grab this they resigned back
to chairman 72-56 52-34
whoo okay eight games in seven games in
another seven for third place see five
all right hang on they might do
something like that
let's let's do this instead so in
exchange Slav by a slight transposition
this Bishop is what one might consider
half developed off the back rank but
beyond that not doing a whole lot you
could very easily just be locked in with
III and that's what we're having and I'm
gonna pinpoint h2 castling is no good
rook c8 first sometimes you might want
to play rook c8 before the Bishop to
deploy so that if doctored might be five
you could just drop back and everything
is coordinated like this so this Bishop
is not in the way of my pieces let's
kick the knight out of there maybe I
should have just jumped in right here I
would have been better I don't want a
castle I want to do this I want to
attack let's do this oh I'm getting I'm
getting forked darn it I'm getting that
piece back got to take that fish up whoa
did I really do that
yes I did yes I did okay on that bishop
let's take with the check I can't move
my knight
yeah I shouldn't have um let's do this
let's do that
wonderful commentary let's do this let's
do that Wow how'd you come up with that
line okay Castle I'm still looking for H
- H - out of nowhere
back to tournament 90-68 54 watch out
for each to John Madden oh no this guy
is super scary
super scary is John Madden ok I think
this is a good line for me how could you
be so sure how can you be so sure it's
because of the e6 square it's a deadly
Ford but John Madden will not go into
the night quietly I promise you it never
happens
light squares Mike we might be excited
about e6 pin the knight attack him it's
going down I'm up a piece I'm up a rook
watch out for the tricky night he is so
tricky that night he is such a tricky
piece do I really have to do that move I
guess so I don't like to have to defend
like that hang on now I'll pin him we
will pin that tricky Knight now
yeah it's back to tournament that was an
important game mr. John Madden doesn't
it usually never goes into the night
quietly and it's almost always down to
the wire almost always last time I think
he I had like I had no time and he had a
ton of time no time versus a ton of time
is a situation you never want to be in
let's do this I'm gonna kick the bishop
away and then get on this diagonal let's
get on this diagonal and actually do
what more let's jump in here I don't
know if that's the best but it's to
control here let's try Mike lean back I
want to get my majority going over here
we're have a space advantage I want to
get in b4 they're gonna play with f3 but
now I'm gonna strike in the center
quickly and try to make this pond
target all right I'm winning upon here
winning upon and winning another one and
this will come with check let me just
drop all the way back yeah let's just
defend stuff okay we're gonna take I
want to get my queen back on this
vulnerable diagonal I'm gonna hang that
pawn I want to come over with this rook
because this one might be under attack I
want to trade Queens and look to pick
off these ponds alright let's get some
lateral movement with my rook I'm gonna
take this and work out this right here
so this is not that's so easy hang on
okay I'm gonna grab this and then I go
here right here 11 seconds is not a lot
okay now I haven't no I have a plan
right here right here I shouldn't let
that pawn get so far down I'm gonna take
it my king is gonna have to run like a
maniac now not cool okay
it's gonna be perpetual it's gonna be
perpetual they didn't go for perpetual
Queens are off oh my goodness
I don't want that's fine but my time was
down I'm so glad to see green watch out
this guy goes after my queen every time
chalk that one up that was a good line
wasn't it it's so I'm so glad to see
green you don't want to see those read
those read a wonderful grammar lesson
going on here wonderful okay what is my
dark-squared bishop doing nothing get
rid of them he's a big idiot he is a big
idiot okay now I want to get this
advancing my knight wants to be here oh
that's a free piece they somethingness
that I had two pieces on though and I'm
gonna come back I like my bishop better
than theirs
okay following up this is what I want to
do assuming that the position was still
balanced let's keep it closed as much as
possible okay my rook is kind of stupid
but maybe not my knight is super
annoying
he's gotta be passed pawn deadly forks
queen on g4 I want to maintain my knight
still fort ideas and that's gonna be
game over right I just want to take
stuff I just want to take stuff get all
my pieces working I did I feel like I
just want to take that pawn but let's
just come over around the open the only
open file should have traded Queens
there this will work - that'll work -
and then grab pawns buy one come back
hang up
let's get this pond the furthest advance
one this one this one and everything
else watch out for stalemate let's run
over here the King is cut off now and
we're going to do it like what just like
this
there we go back to China 150 126 86 85
13 minutes remaining
for sure Karev okay um maybe I could get
in F maybe I could try that now okay I
was thinking about let's try it let's
see if I could do this okay so I got
away with playing this before my king
Knight develops I don't know if that
should have been allowed
I should probably maintain my knight so
now my knight maintains pressure on this
point h6 is purposeful it keeps the
knight out of here and now eventually
this push knows it's gonna be a pain
that Knights gonna be a pain okay my
bishop springs to life my Knight wants
to jump in here my bishop wants to be
here bishop check maybe I want to hit
the knight first let's throw that in
first that's got to be a bit annoying
yeah let's jump my knight in here I'm
hitting the rook I don't want to take
any piece just yet
get my rook on this open file no I want
to get my Queen doing something not good
at taking the rope okay my night still
defended hitting their Knight tricky
Knights I'm on this night defending this
pawn he's getting this let's do this in
push gonna save that pawn dark squares
get on them I'm on the rook they missed
it
let's drop back to defend both pawns get
rid of that Knight oh he could take here
oh he didn't
yeah you could have just taken there
that nights running way short on squares
way sure and last thing - okay they
resigned I was gonna say get on the g5
around yeah the G file and put pressure
on that g3 point
let's try d4 okay I like this idea okay
a lot of pawn moves a lot of pawn moves
so I'm gonna throw this H pond down make
some more weaknesses and my knight wants
to be on g4 actually pun I'm gonna win
upon its pinned that Knights pinned
that's check I want to shut down this
Bishop and I feel like I want a sack
here yeah I definitely want a sack I
don't know if it's right going to try it
though I was gonna push right away oh
they didn't do that hmm pick up the
exchange the Knights gonna jump in here
have to be a bit cautious okay yeah
this is this is a bit scary let's let's
just get castled just want to do this to
defend that square oh boy get off of
that keep that night away okay I got to
do this
my knight I have to be very cautious
about moving my knight that'd be two
point is scary here all right let's just
trade they didn't go with that okay
exchange how could I make this work get
out of tricky stuff here get my knight
right here right here I'm gonna get rid
of one of their bishops King up as a
good improvement on this pawn as well
let's defend this first okay I open file
my rooks working I have the control of
the only two open files and this should
be much easier to pre move now
a lot of this is going to drop now
pressure on that pond keep pressure on
that pond could just take that and win
this I have to go fast I have to go fast
here okay
okay they're down a time back to
tournament I thought I was gonna still
have to get another another queen but
they were they were down there 191 66
Sandra 9 guy that we were watching
earlier play that five-minute game
submission akov rarely do I play this in
the the bull games so far so book right
here no still going with this night
jumps in here Bishop takes c4 c3 c3
Bishop here if Bishop g4 Bishop here I
want to put pressure on this night but
let's do this first and drop this pawn I
didn't mean to do that I didn't mean to
do that okay challenge this square ok
he's challenged he's not being taken
back though man I shouldn't have done
that
okay let's see let's get this advanced
in he's a liability for as long as he's
around my knight is an extra I'm on the
bishop I really don't want to give up my
knight right here that's a sneaky move
sneaky move that actually works I'll
take it
I'm up another piece grab that pond run
away with my knight give one piece back
and then just win it from this position
now it comes all the way back flight
square King up stay connected is the
plan connectivity points King position
throwing some checks maybe on the pond
all right I didn't take the pun I'm on
the pot again now I'll take them not so
fast yes I could bring with that pawn up
on up with check row trade in position
can I go faster let's target this pawn
next with a check oh that's a deadly
discovery no stalemates no stalemates
no stalemates and then me all right back
to tyrant 210 210 176 142 blue flame all
right benoni I should have supported it
with e4 okay now I have you for a six is
a four I want to do this because I don't
want to allow my opponents yet they get
rid of their LightSquared bishop I had
to anticipate capture of Bishop g4 this
Knight is looking to reposition maybe
I'm all of a sudden okay with giving up
my LightSquared Bishop if I did have
play on the a file maybe he kept this
advance in I could have considered
taking here I'm gonna do it now and then
if Bishop takes pawn I think I could
take here first let's just target this
pawn pawn push oh that's not working I
have too much on that one pretty sure I
have too much on that one okay clean
takes and I could jump in here no it
could jump here pick up the exchange and
then do what next if the knight moves I
get the bishop where does my dark square
Bishop want to be brain cramp okay let's
go over here oh man what's that let's
get rid of that fish up dropping this at
the end of it have another pawn get my
bishop working
guard that pond 17 seconds and then do
what next why am I not moving
oh my goodness why fights takes so long
to move right there
11 seconds oh I got a foot CIFOR gets a
fork no oh wait I get this okay now I
gotta win this stupid ending I'm still
up King position pounds on light why'd
it go there
King position get out of there
here no matter what think
let's check okay I'll go down there down
on time to 32 16 16 games in - 32 16 1 8
I couldn't see that last one um this guy
gonna move yes he is that was not a
quick win why'd I do that
I should have done um I meant to do this
this is way to weakening might be ok
though if I could get this advance in
okay now I could get it in I have a good
center and I'm supporting this I could
capture if they go there I have enough
material on it you get the rook maybe in
a castle Castle queenside throw my H
pond down look for made on each one it's
the plan look for me right here pawn
push this is check I'm on the night
you're gonna resign let's check tricky
discoveries oh I could have taken the
rook there's a better way to do this oh
okay
where's the mate Oh Queen here close to
mingle
there's no stalemate sneak in here mate
next pretty sure okay back to tournament
250 250 216 3 minutes 20 seconds ex
extinguisher can't pronounce these names
okay all right I wasted tempo there did
you catch that
that was a tempo waste place that nine
to pin okay they're not doing anything
about that hang out over here get my
knight in to f4 f5 you know what I meant
I shouldn't have done that right away
I'm on the rook they'll hang on let's
get over here open up that H file drop
my bishop back clean trade now do the
Knights have any homes I shouldn't have
given that check that was unnecessary
hang on King position no rook position
open this up here take my bishop alright
I just want to open that up my rook has
some play now
okay that's check the knight was ready
to come into a good spot I think okay
King position that tricky Knight is
still around he is still around it was
not gonna get active one day somebody
tell me finally go after the weak link
as soon as this pawn falls then you do
what you've run with the ape on like a
crazy person
run like a crazy person keep running
watch out for the tricky checks I also
have my rook here to stop the King from
doing what exactly
from getting active he's running away
that was made I missed it that was made
to probably oh no no no no no no that
would have been a bad pre-move oh my
goodness pickoff pawns would you are
they down in time no they're checkmated
272 oh yeah 270 I couldn't see who was
in second place oh my goodness my heart
is racing it's racing - believe me watch
out for f7 that was a note to self that
was a note to self get rid of the light
square bishop just push here okay kill
the light square bishop look for me
f2 is hit f2 is not being addressed and
we have a mate threat deadly discoveries
Queen h3 and then a knight move is
killer that's a killer isn't it and I
hear the bishop has to block I could
take this pawn with check there had to
have been a better move there
okay I could just take that Oh the
qubits have been assigned the it's not
gonna finish there's only 18 seconds
with check
oh did not finish alright first place
confetti closeout - 7244 - 22 196
alrighty good games oh okay it's been a
while for tournament